[MUSIC]
Okay, hi everyone,
thank you for joining us.
My name is Carl and I'm a second
year MBA student here at the GSB.
I'm joined by Heather one of my friends
and classmates and second year as well.
So today we'll be talking about our
experiences at the GSB both in and outside
of the classroom and we'll be answering
as many of your questions as we can.
We won't be talking about the admissions
process, financial aid, or
the application.
But we have some people from
the admissions office who are going to
be available via chat, or
you can email them as well.
If you want to submit a question, you can
just click the Q&A button at the bottom of
your screen, and then we'll be
able to see the questions in life.
Just to start,
maybe we can start with introductions.
So maybe Heather, if you can start by
telling us a little bit about yourself,
where you're from,
what you did before the GSB, and what
you're planning to do after graduation?
>> Sure, hi everybody,
my name is Heather and I as Carla said,
a second year MBA student.
I'm a born and raised mid Westerner and
I spent the last four years in Chicago
working in management consulting
before coming to the GSB.
I came to the GSB because I was really
focused on making a pivot into social
innovation.
And this seems like the best
school in the country to do that.
Here at the GSB I've been
involved in a lot of things.
I was on our GSB Impact Fund,
which is our impact investing group.
I help with our admin weekend,
and this year,
I'm in Arbuckle fellow which we
can talk a little bit more about.
It's a program focused on coaching and
mentorship.
I spend the summer at Rafi,
they are a sustainable shoe company and
I'll be going back there
full time after graduation.
>> Amazing, congratulation.
>> Thank you.
>> As for myself, my name is Carl,
as I said,
I'm originally from Montreal in Canada.
And prior to the GSB, I was working as
an anestesiology residents physician.
So working mostly at
the operating room and
as part of the trauma and
cardiac arrest teams in my hospital.
I came to the GSB because I was interested
in health care systems reform and
healthcare administration and
wanted to be bilingual in some way,
be able to talk to both clinicians and
administrators.
And here at the GSB,
I'm also an Arbuckle fellow like Heather.
I am also involved with
the Students Association
as Chief Operating Officer, and
I'm a member of several clubs including
the Black Business Student Association,
GSB Pride, and the Healthcare Club.
My summer was spent in to parts actually.
For the first part I worked at company,
the management consulting firm.
And then for the second half I went
back to my old job at the operating room
to see some patients.
And after school, directly after
I'll be finishing my residency, but
do have a return offer to join
company full-time afterwards.
>> Yay, [LAUGH]
>> So,
maybe we can start with some questions.
So Heather, why an MBA?
And what made you decide to come here,
do an MBA, and why now?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
So, for me, I went back and forth on
whether I wanted to get an MBA for
a long time.
Is something that is pretty typical for
consultants, so I knew that it was
an option for me although not a necessary
feature to continue my career.
Honestly, if I have a piece of advice it's
apply before you know that you want to go.
I went back and forth and
from the time you apply to the time you
actually leave for school takes a year.
So in hindsight, I probably should
have applied a year previous to go and
I was actually ready to go.
But ultimately, I just decided that I
kind of would had an epiphany in terms
of what I was doing wasn't what I wanted
to do for the rest of my life anymore.
And it seems like this
was a really good way for
me to do that self reflection and
spend two years doing some exploration and
figuring out where I wanted
to go in my career and
what I was looking to get out of it,
and I think I've gotten that here.
>> Amazing, yeah, I think I have
a pretty similar story for that.
I tried to balance essentially having
enough experience that I felt like
I knew what my role was as a doctor and
I knew I had experiences to
share with my classmates.
But also had time to come back
after I finished my residency and
still catch up with my clinical
work when I came back.
I think the other thing is leaving
a salary of a resident is very
different than leaving a salary
as an attendant for two years.
And so I was more comfortable doing
my MBA earlier in my career before
my earnings start jumping
up significantly.
So far next question, what made you decide
to apply into Stanford over other schools?
>> Yeah, so
I applied to a bunch of different schools.
My husband actually lives in Chicago, and
so we were making this a lot
of these decisions in tandem.
And so a big piece of it for
us was, where could I go to school
where he could easily find a new job.
So we were really looking in major
labor markets, so no small schools for
me and kind of the middle of nowhere.
So I was really only looking at schools in
big cities and then I was really focused
on the curriculum and
what I could get out of it and.
And I knew for
me that looks like social innovation.
So I was looking at schools that had
great social innovation programs and
then great design thinking programs.
Those were kind of my two criteria.
And so ultimately, that ended up being
a handful of schools and when I got into
Stanford I was like, love this, these
were the things that I was looking for.
So it's kind of hard to deny that
this was the place to be, yeah
>> Awesome, yeah.
For me, I think one of the big
things that I was looking for
was a school that also has a very
reputable healthcare system associated
with it because shockingly,
I'm interested in healthcare.
Also, I was super attracted
to the focus that Stanford has on personal
development and leadership development.
And all the classes that are available
here to work on your leadership brand and
learn more about how other people
perceive your leadership behavior is
what's super interesting to me.
And I think the last thing
is being international,
I wanted to go to a school that
had some brand recognition in my
home market since I know that I'm planning
to go back there after graduation.
Okay, next question.
Carl, how was your experience in the
beginning of the MBA course considering
that you did not have
a traditional business background?
How did the school help you
during this transition period?
I think there's a few different things.
First having a non-traditional
background in the first few
quarters a lot of the classes are tiered.
So there's a base level and
accelerated level and an advanced level.
And so for
me who hadn't taken accounting before knew
very little about finance, it was helpful
to take the base classes in some cases
accelerated is also appropriate.
Whereas my classmates who came from
finance or consulting backgrounds
were probably skewed more towards
the accelerated and advanced classes.
Also, we got sent materials over
the summer that we could look over
if we needed to review certain things,
mainly in math and
statistics, which I
looked into a little bit.
And there's also a lot of tutoring
resources that are available for us.
To access all throughout
our two years in campus.
>> And I think one of the other
interesting things to note there that is
the GSB specific thing is we have
an academic adjustment period for
the first six weeks of your first year.
You're not allowed to join the clubs,
recruiters aren't allowed to come to
campus, and those six weeks are purely for
you to kind of focus on getting your
feet underneath your academics life.
>> Mm-hm, yeah,
that was definitely useful for
me as someone who's never
studied business before.
Next question, Heather, can you speak
a little bit more about the social impact
opportunities at Stanford and unique
programs this school has in the space?
>> Mm-hm, sure, so
we have a one of the biggest resources
here on campus is the Center for
Social Innovation.
They are sort of a conduit or
a plethora of resources for
you in career preparation,
as well as plotting your academic journey.
So when you come to school, they sort
of talk to you about your two year
roadmap and then beyond that, what does
it look like once you leave the GSB.
They bucket you into one of
I think four categories, so
you might be a career switcher, or
you might be an industry vet, or
you might just be an explorer,
just kind of interested in the field.
So based on that they kind of help
give you guidance on on what to do.
I think one of the other great resources
that we have available is you can actually
get a certificate here, a certificate in
social innovation and public management.
And we're generalizing BA program,
we don't do specific tracks,
that's one of our only
certificate programs.
So I think that's been a really great
way to sort of add credentials to my MBA
showing that this isn't area of focus.
And then I joined a lot of social impact
type opportunity in terms of clubs.
So we have a club for
sustainable business, we have a club for
social innovation, I joined our
social impact start up that we would
invest in, and then I am the CEO
of the Challenge for Charity which is
the largest MBA nonprofit in the country.
So they were things that were important
to me I found ways to work them into,
none of my course work but
my extra curriculars,
and just other opportunity,
yeah, my internship.
>> Amazing, GSB focuses a lot on shaping
leaders, what kind of leaders and
what are the leadership values
that form the ethos of the GSB?
>> Mm-hm, do you want to start?
>> Sure, I'll start, I think a big thing
that I've learned during my time here
is that there's not one kind of
leader that can be effective.
There's so many people who
are extremely different than me here,
and they're just as effective as me if not
more in a lot of different situations.
And I think a big strength in
the GP is that they help you narrow
in on what your brand is, and
what situation is this brand effective,
and what situation could you tweak it, in
a way that still feels authentic to you.
And I think in terms of what they look
for, passion is certainly something that
resonated a lot with me when
I was visiting the school,
when I was talking to the students.
I think it's not a coincidence that the
question in the essay is what matters most
to you and why.
They really want to get at
what you're passionate about,
what drives you,
what gets you out of bed in the morning.
>> I agree with all of that,
I think if you were to ask people,
just ask them in general public like
what is the brand of GSB leadership?
They would probably talk to you about how
we're sort of in touch with our feelings
and our emotions, and I would say
that's definitely been a big focus
intentionally of my first year and a half.
Has really been doing this self-reflection
and identifying what I want to get out of
being a leader or being in business,
what it is that drives me,
what it is that I'm passionate about, and
how I want to show up to other people.
And I think one of the most
valuable pieces of the GSB is that,
there's just this assumption here that
everyone has the best intent possible, and
there is this culture of feedback.
And it's really a gift to
other people to let them know
how you perceive them and
how they are showing up to you
because that is not always information
that you get in the real world.
And so what you may intend to do
based on how you're speaking or
what you're doing,
may not be how other people perceive it.
And so that's been a really valuable part
of this experience to me is understanding
how my intent differs from
the impact that I have on others.
And so
I think that that is a self aware leader,
I guess is where I think
that GSP tries to push us.
>> Yeah, definitely agree with that.
Next question, what was your most
memorable experience at the GSB?
want to start with that one?
>> Sure, wow, they're so many.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, my first challenge for
charity weekend, which was last year,
was a really great culminating experience
of a lot of hard work throughout the year.
And then also an opportunity to host other
business schools here which helped us or
helped me see GSB through their eyes,
which is kind of fun.
And I'm trying to think that I also
loved our Vegas foam, [LAUGH] so
our foam is just a weekly social
event that we have on Tuesday nights,
and it's just like a kind of
a happy hour type experience.
And once a year,
we all dress up in 70s clothes and
we take a cheap Southwest flight to Vegas
for the night, and then we come back.
And that's not normally something I think
I would participate in at this stage in my
life but it is really fun to do
with 200 of your closest friends.
So that was a very memorable experience,
and then otherwise,
I think just the friendships
that I've made and
the trips we've taken together,
that's been a big part.
>> Yeah, I think for me also,
a lot of these travel opportunities
have really memorable for me.
I actually met Heather before we even
got to campus on a trip to Singapore and
Malaysia that was organized In
the context of our program.
And so we spend two weeks in
those countries learning about
their approach to artificial
intelligence and big data.
And it was such a great opportunity for
me to meet some of my classmates
from different backgrounds.
To get to know them in a bit
of a Smaller environment and
really feel like I had a lot of friendly
faces on campus when I already got there.
And on top of that I got to learn about
a new industry learned about two new
countries experience their culture.
What was really exceptional?
>> This is a fun question.
So can I add two more?
>> Yeah, go
>> really quickly.
So when Carl and I are very,
very good friends.
I actually had the honor
of introducing Carl, for
like a big event that he did on campus.
He gave a big speech.
And so that was a really memorable I think
opportunity for us together and then For
me and another big piece,
because we're Arbuckle fellows,
we had the opportunity to take the
interpersonal dynamics class last spring.
And that's sort of a small group
type learning for Focused on, yeah,
self-awareness, sometimes
called touchy-feely, and
that course had a huge impact on me
not only in a professional setting but
how I approach my relationships and
friendships and it has really impacted
a lot about how I live my life.
So [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, those two were also really-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Really impactful experiences for
me definitely.
Next can you speak more on the health care
focused opportunities, both at the GSP and
beyond, for example, classes, clubs,
exit opportunities, etcetera.
I think I can take that one.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Good.
>> I have taken a lot of healthcare
classes both at the GSP and
what we call across the street,
so in other Standford faculties.
I've taken one on innovation in healthcare
where each class is about a different
segment of the healthcare industry.
We had lots of speakers come in and CEOs
of Pharma companies, biotech companies,
of drug discovery and medical device
companies, to talk to us about how they
perceive the industries, what
are the major trends within their segment.
And that was super interesting for
me to see health care from the sort of
the business perspective rather
than the clinical perspective.
I've also taken a health care
operations management class, where I've
learned how to take large chunks of
data of hospital patient transfers.
And then see in a consulting type
of project how we could optimize transfers
between the different departments.
In terms of the club,
our health care club is very active.
They always organize brown bag lunches
with different speakers from startups and
large companies alike.
They organized this week a trek to
a bunch of the startups operating in
the mental health space in Silicon Valley.
And they're also organizing a large
conference later in the spring.
And finally you were asking
about exit opportunities.
I think there's people who do all sorts
of things within health care, whether
health care investing, in VC, some people
will go work at health care startups.
Some people will do general
health care administration.
Some people like me will work
as clinicians with leadership roles
within the health care system.
And so, I think the world is kind of your
oyster within the health care industry
once you leave here.
Is there anything you
wish you had known or
done differently before
coming into the MBA?
>> Yes,
I think that the opportunities that you're
presented at Stanford are numerous.
There's always going to be
a lot of competing options for
your time and attention.
At any given time, there's four brown
bag lunches that you want to go to, and
they're all great.
I just had a, was sending emails, and my
co-founder was like, I'm going to go see
this former founder, can you go talk
to the VC people in the other room?
And so it's a matter of making choices
about the opportunities that you take.
And I think something that would have
helped me was to do a little bit more
introspection and figure out my focus and
goals before I came here.
I had this general idea that I wanted
a reason or a mission to get up in
the morning and to go to work, and
that was doing good in the world.
But I had no idea what that meant,
and I think a tangible example of that for
me is I was applying for our Impact Fund.
And we do investment deals
in a variety of areas,
in financial technology,
health care, education, energy and
environment, urban development,
kind all over the place.
And they asked us to choose
what we were interested in, and
I knew that I was interested in investing
in things that were good for the world.
But I had no idea which of those
spaces I was actually interested in.
And that meant that I was kind of all
over the place, and I didn't focus.
Then once I was able to sort of
narrow in on what it was that I
truly cared the most about,
life got a lot easier for me,
it was a lot easier to say no to
things that weren't quite relevant.
I think there's always this element of,
well, everybody dropped their resume at
Google, I should probably drop
my resume at Google, too.
And maybe that's true, but maybe it's not.
And so just knowing some of these things
about yourself before you come here, and
all of these shiny objects
are thrown at you,
I think can be a really helpful exercise.
>> Yeah, I'll go in a slightly
different direction for this one.
I wish I had known more about the power
of, first, of Stanford network, but
also the Stanford email.
An example that I've given a few people
recently is that over the past months,
I've emailed four hospital CEOs just to
ask them to sit down and chat with me.
And all four them responded.
Three out of the four
responded within 24 hours, and
we set up little, small,
short calls of half an hour.
And they were all very willing to tell me
about their experiences, about how they
got to where they got, and to give me
advice on how to get to where they are at.
And so had I known about that earlier,
I think I would have taken much
more advantage of that last year,
even as soon as I got my Stanford
email when I first got it.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, that makes sense.
>> What has been the greatest
challenge you have faced at Stanford?
>> Hm, do you want to start?
>> Okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'll take that one.
I think two things.
First, I'm an international student.
And so adapting to a new culture
in a new country has been
more difficult than I anticipated.
Especially because I come from Canada, so
I expected the culture to be very similar,
but there are some differences.
In terms of the politics, in terms of the
culture, the cultural references, and so
it was kind of interesting for me to
realize that I was in a very different
environment sort of mid way
through my fall quarter.
And had I braced myself a bit more for
that,
I think my transition would
have been a bit smoother.
And the other thing is time management.
As Heather was mentioning, there's so
many opportunities that are thrown at you
here all the time that it's hard sometimes
to decide which one is
the best use of your time.
>> I would definitely
echo time management.
I think for me, the second dimension
is much more personal, and
that's that my husband lives in Chicago,
and so we're in a long-distance marriage.
We got married two months before I moved
here to start my two-year MBA program.
And that's hard, we're doing well, but
of course, we would rather be together.
So I think just figuring out, I think a
lot of people struggle with how to balance
their relationships and
lives pre-GSP with the fact that this is
an all-consuming experience that you
really want to be present for and
take advantage of over the two
years that you're here.
So finding that balance for yourself and
how to take care of yourself and
your other relationships
outside of the GSP.
>> What's the single most important area
Stanford has offered you to improve your
market value so far?
>> Ooh, my market value.
>> Yeah, that's a very interesting one.
I think I have an idea, actually.
>> Great.
>> I would say it's made me more aware
of my market value, if anything.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think as someone who was more
an individual contributor,
I didn't realize how valuable
the skills that I already
possessed before the GSP were.
And I didn't realize that there were so
many different things that I could be
doing within and outside health care with
what I've learned both here and before.
And so I think Stanford has
taught me to think big and
to know that if I work hard and if I'm
passionate about what I'm doing, I can
accomplish a lot of things that I never
even thought were possible in the past.
>> I'm going to fork this
in two directions, I think.
First, what I think outside
perception of my market value is.
And then where I actually think my
market value has improved the most from
an internal perspective, because I
think those are different things.
From the outside perspective, honestly,
just the signal of a Stanford MBA
credential is what I think has
improved my market value the most.
There are groups that I emailed
beforehand, as I consulted at
very good consulting firm prior to
the GSP, when I was kind of thinking about
different career options, when I was
debating between that and business school.
And I never got an email back.
And then suddenly you are a Stanford MBA,
and everyone emails you back.
So just having the credential is
in of itself of market value, and
that feels a little transactional to say,
but I think it's there.
And then internally where I actually
think that I have gained the most market
value is in the soft skills, absolutely.
I think that before when I was in really
high pressure consulting environments,
it was easy for me to be impatient or
speak sharply in a way that
could be demotivating to a team.
And I really learned how to adapt sort of
a firm style with being a little bit more
empathetic in ways that I think will
maybe they'll come across in interviews,
maybe they'll be valued.
But they will certainly be valued
when I'm managing teams or
leading teams and the fact that I feel
much more equipped to develop and
grow a team to their utmost potential.
>> How collaborative is the GSB
environment do the second year students
help with recruiting preparation is
the classroom dynamics friendly?
>> Yeah, classroom dynamics very friendly.
We have a student agreed upon
norm here a grade non disclosure,
which means that to recruiters, you
aren't allowed to share your class rank,
you're not allowed to share your GPA.
So it's super collaborative,
I think last year.
People were building certain guides and
sending them out
to the entire class saying hi, I can pile
all the slide, good luck on your finals.
So definitely collaborative and
helpful if not competitive [LAUGH]
I don't think at all and then.
What was the other half of the question?
>> Do second year students help
with recruiting preparation?
>> Yeah, a large portion of our
classes interested in slightly more
entrepreneurial ventures.
I think where I see the most help
in career preparation is that
if there's somebody that's in the field
that you want to go into, they will
if you email them and they're like, hey,
can we sit down for 30 minutes for coffee?
They will tell you about
their summer experience.
We do a ton of panels on like,
what did I do last summer?
How did I go through that process?
What did it look like?
And then there are a few things that
are a little bit more institutionalized.
And so, and for consulting for example,
I ran cases with a lot of people last year
to help prepare them for
their case interviews.
And maybe you can speak more
about that from your perspective.
>> Yeah, I was recruiting for
consulting and obviously we have a lot
of classmates who work in consulting.
We have a consulting club, and so,
I lean into both of those resources pretty
heavily to prepare for my interviews.
And that, honestly that made the
difference between me getting the job or
not at the end of the day.
So, I think it's incredibly collaborative.
The other thing I'll say about
that is that we all become kind of
known to each other because the class size
is small enough that you have at least
an idea of what people are interested in,
what they're like a little bit.
And so
whenever I hear of an opportunity and
social impact or in fashion, for example,
I'll think of Heather immediately.
And if she hears of
something within healthcare,
like healthcare systems policy
like she'll think of me.
And so opportunities kind of
get redirected a lot like that
which is super helpful for
us to achieve our goals and
learn about things that we wouldn't
have heard about otherwise.
>> I think people are super generous
with their networks here and
pass along job opportunities that
might be of interest all the time.
And if there's something
that you mentioned,
they'll be like I have
a friend that does that.
Let me introduce you.
So I think that's been.
That are super helpful.
>> Yeah, definitely.
How was your experience with
the application process, and
what is your piece of advice
to potential applicants?
>> Great, and I think this will
probably have to be our last question.
>> I think so.
>> So the experience with
the application question,
I think Stanford was by far the most
involved application that I completed.
So I would say open it up and
look through it entirely.
Well in advance of the deadline if you if
you know the essay prompts and you think
you'll just do that and filling your name
and address, there's more to it than that.
So look in advance.
And but
overall the application process was great.
I think my advice for
you is well, first of all,
again this is a black box, none of us
knows exactly why we were admitted.
So we don't say anything on
behalf of the admissions office.
But for me I think it was really
important to me that I show that I
was a well rounded person
who had interests and
passions and just things that
I cared about outside of work.
And if you have turned your passion
into your work, that is great,
talk about your work by all means but,
all the facets of your personality.
>> Yeah,
I think the only thing I'll add to that is
just try to be as authentic as you can.
None of us know what the admissions
office is looking for.
So you may as well be
your authentic self so
that you know that the person they
accepted is the person you actually
are not a person that you've tried to
manufacture for an admissions committee.
I think they're very intentional
about creating a community and you
want to know that you're the person that
they wanted as part of this community.
>> Self reflection is good.
>> Definitely.
So, we're almost out
of time unfortunately.
But before we go Heather,
do you have any final words to share with
the applicants or a piece or advice?
>> This is the greatest two years ever.
So, just have fun, try not to stress
too much, the allocation process
seems never ending, but
it's really worth it on the other side.
So, yeah, try to enjoy it and use it as
an opportunity for self reflection and
then do more of that over your two years
of business school wherever you go.
>> Amazing.
Thanks, everyone for joining us, and
we hope you learned a lot over
the course of this panel.
>> Thank you.
[MUSIC]